violence is not the answer in
retaliation isn't the solution you know
race is the elephant in the room and we
all understand that they just get
offended and figured god we deserve
alright absolutely when you have an
intelligent black man who speaks a
certain way they say oh he's such a nice
guy he speaks so well and I think it's
disrespectful to say that I speak well
because it's assuming that since I'm a
black kid and I'm not supposed to be
properly and I think that growing up for
me to carry myself a certain way and to
be held to that like to wear if it's a
white athlete comes in it's just that oh
he's mature he's educated when it says
african-american athlete it's all he
speaks well to caught off guard I think
the other comparisons you could make
between how African American athletes
are treated in white when Odell Beckham
explodes on the sideline is a problem
when another player does it like Tom
Brady he's passionate he cares about his
teammates he loves the game he can curse
out his coach and the other guy doesn't
and it's not it's not viewed the same
way that's a problem in society as an
athlete and a black athlete at that like
I have a voice whenever opportunity
presents itself and I can use it I'm
gonna speak out on it a lot of us do a
lot of positive things that don't make
it to the media but once some negative
happens there's see no headlines you
know it sent a page in front page like
if I'm gonna newsroom I feel like
everybody's gonna get it asked to Jack
no question to like kind of tear the
team down I feel like every interview
every media outlet is just trying to
tear down but
well let us play basketball that's all
I'm saying
and now when I want to talk to y'all a
problem with me come on man
grow up and when I say protect the game
they say protected business and I think
that's what separates the athlete from
the human and we've gone too far into
the business side where we are trying to
make these cookie cutter players this is
the way you act this is the way you
speak just like everybody else we make
mistakes and I think that's the most
fearful part you know it doesn't have to
be on the court you know your actions on
the court and how you carry yourself
it's off the court we can't do
everything that you know nobody no one's
can do you know there's select few of us
I have the opportunity to make it out
and you know that can be by design you
know let if you get out and they'll be
come on our side you know it's kind of
like that the house Negro you got the
middle class that they have the hope to
get out they have the opportunity and
maybe they do and and what we tend to do
is separate ourselves from field Negroes
and that's been put in place since the
beginning of this country not that you
have a platform it gives you opportunity
having boys so what is it that you think
that makes players a little hesitant I
feel like sometimes when people were
hesitant it could be the backlash or the
branding branding plays a part into you
know a lot of it and you know your
sponsors may not like what you say or
you know what you condone or don't
condone and things like that nature and
some people may just feel like they may
be saying the wrong thing you know or
they may not be too knowledgeable owner
or that their opinion may not hold that
much weight or it's a lot of things I
can factor into it but I think backlash
might be there the biggest one for sure
people are afraid of what they don't
know a lot of times you're afraid to
expose yourself or to kind of talk about
things that that may hurt you and I
think that as a society and as a man a
lot of times we don't want to be
emotional we don't want to talk about
things that upset us and I think in the
culture of African Americans and the
households like mom always tell you what
happens in the house stays in the house
and and a lot of other societies it's
okay to talk about things that are going
on and things that bother you so I think
that we have to get rid of that negative
stigma and it starts with how we're
raised and where we grow up back
black box matter with the black fist
once a victim always a victim all lives
matter our [ __ ] die get offended and
triggered Bradley you're an idiot for
posting this right now [ __ ] Bradley Beal
I feel like the only bad feeling I would
have is because kids that I do mentor
and that I do view me as a role model
have to see all of it on my page those
comments those do not bother because
they could be the same people that I
walk across the street from they wave
and say hi - yeah I was reading more
okay lost a lot of respect for this guy
that was just dumb period maybe he
should just try keeping his mouth shut
do a massive thing
it's sad most black athletes are
unintelligent and don't know their
history Thomas like that I've reached
him to daily just obey the law simple
next time take your hands out of your
pocket just because you're famous no
means [ __ ] car I'll do what I want all
right I own this right here they didn't
know I was you know they know who I was
when it happened you know so me being
famous had nothing to do with the
situation but you know that's that's why
I'm doing what I'm doing that's why I'm
speaking up and ways I am so I can try
to you know bring change
I sister family in this lifestyle you
have to be careful with what you do how
you move and where you go and we social
media a lot of things can be
misconstrued
[Music]